now if the oscars are a delicious
cupcake the fashion
might be the decadent icing you know you
heard me oh she can't have one without
the other
i did you know i was like i need a dress
on right now um and we want to see how
well we remember some of
the red carpet's greatest hits
are you guys ready to play that game
let's go yes it's time to play guess
that drag yes
hear how it's gonna work
we'll check out a stunning oscar dress
from oscar history and see if we can
guess that dress are you ready to play
yes all right up first and i do not know
these answers i have any names i already
know
i don't know we'll see what happens all
right next next let's guess this dress
hallelujah
halle berry
was all right next thing that's this
dress
yes iconic oh goodness i mean i really
don't want to sit next to her anymore i
mean she shouts out everything you know
to me the best gwyneth dress was that
white sheath thompson
i don't think anyone has looked better
at an oscar ever than her okay and
finally our final dress who is angelina
[Applause]
yeah that moment became super iconic
well kevin michelle i can't wait to
recap with you guys and see what really
happened on the big night
and um
i just i i'd love the opportunity to be
able to do this with you guys every time
more award shows because i we just have
so much fun doing them
kevin frazier and nichelle turner
obviously you can watch them every night
as i do on entertainment tonight and we
all do that's right baby and don't
forget the oscars air on abc this sunday
march 27th at 8pm eastern we hope
everyone has a great night
[Music]